i'm pretty sure i just tore my calf
muscle this morning while
sprinting with my son but the math must
not stop
so i'm here to help us think about
what we could call influential points
when we're thinking about regressions
and to help us here i have this tool
from bfw publishing i encourage you to
go here and use this tool
yourself but what it allows us to do is
to draw some points
so just like that let me draw some
points
and then fit a least squares line so
that's the least squares line right over
there
and you can not only see the line we can
see our correlation coefficient it's
pretty good
0.8156 it's pretty close to one so we
have a pretty good
fit right over here but we're going to
think about are
points that might influence or might be
overly influential we could say
to different aspects of this regression
line
so one type of influential point is
known as an outlier
and a good way of identifying an outlier
is it's a very bad fit to the line or it
has a very
large residual and so if i put a point
right over here that is an outlier so
what happens when we have an outlier
like that
so before we had a correlation
coefficient of 0.8
something you put one outlier like that
out of it's now one of
one out of 16 points it dramatically
lowered our correlation coefficient
because we have a really large residual
right over here
so an outlier like this has been very
influential on the correlation
coefficient
it didn't impact the slope of the line
a tremendous amount it did a little bit
it'll actually when i put it there
didn't
impact the slope much at all and it does
impact
the y-intercept a little bit actually
when i put it out here doesn't impact
the y-intercept much at all if i
put it a little bit more to the left it
impacts it a little bit but these
outliers that are at least close to the
mean x value these seem to be most
relevant
in terms of impacting or most
influential in terms of the correlation
coefficient
now what about an outlier that's further
away from the mean
x value and something a point whose x
value
is further away from the mean x values
considered a high leverage point and the
way you could think about that if
if you imagine this is being some type
of a seesaw
somehow pivoted on the mean x value well
if you put
a point out here it looks like it's
pivoting down it's like someone's
sitting at this end of the seesaw and so
that's where i think the term leverage
comes from and you can see when i put an
outlier
if i put a high leverage outlier out
here
that does many things it definitely
drops the correlation coefficient
it changes the slope and it changes
the y-intercept so it does a lot of
things so it's
highly influential for everything i just
talked about
now if i have a high leverage point
that's maybe a little bit
less of an outlier something like this
based on the points that i happen to
have it didn't hurt the correlation
coefficient in fact in that example it's
actually improved it a little bit
but it did change the y-intercept a bit
and it did change the slope a bit
although obviously not as dramatic as
when you do something like that and that
kills the correlation coefficient as
well let's see what happens if we do
things over here
so if i have a high leverage outlier
over here you see the same thing a high
leverage outlier
seems to influence everything if it is a
high leverage point that is less of an
outlier
actually once again it improved the
correlation coefficient
you could say that it's still
influential on the correlation
coefficient in this case it's improving
it
but it's less influential in terms of
the slope and the y-intercept although
it is making a difference there
so i encourage you to play with this
think about different points
how far they are they are away from the
mean x value
how large of a residual they have are
they an outlier and
how influential they are to the various
aspect
aspects of a least squares line the
slope the y-intercept or the correlation
coefficient when we're talking about
correlation coefficient
also known as the r value which is of
course the square root of r squared